Elsa seemed weird to you
what would I do without you you'll
always have me Anna your sister needs
you more than ever
and we don't doubt that you'll be there
to lend a helping hand problem is there
are some things that Elsa needs to
figure out on her own but that's never
stopped her from appreciating you you
would run through fire to save your
sister and that hasn't gone unnoticed
you might not have powers of your own
honor but you are the bravest girl and
all the enchanted land elsa is lucky to
have you but don't forget about Kristoff
the boy keeps trying to propose you're
too preoccupied to notice Elsa Anna and
the boys are about to embark on the
journey of a lifetime things are bound
to get heated up and we have Elsa to
thank for that
keep watching to find out the truth
about Elsa's diverse powers then don't
run into fire the entrance to the
enchanted lands force don't stand at the
entrance of the enchanted land and each
one of them has a different sigil on it
frozen fans have long since concluded
that each one of the symbols relates to
an element this it's fitting to the
enchanted lands are bursting at the
seams with magic and each element seems
to have a place at the heart of the
forest once upon a time when King Agner
and Queen Adina were just kids they
roamed through the forest like it was
nobody's business and magic with a
welcome sight but one day something
terrible happened and the entrance to
the enchanted land was closed for good
in the new trailer we see Anna Elsa and
the boys walk through the very same
entrance but this time it's covered by
mist and seemingly impenetrable
luckily Elsa is able to disperse the
mist and walk into the enchanted lands
with her sister and friends Elsa is an
open channel
Elsa may look and talk like everyone
else but comparing her to others is like
comparing oranges to bananas Elsa is in
tune with nature in a very special way
and she can see and hear things that
other people can't but sometimes being
an open channel isn't all that it's
cracked up to be
and Elsa is living proof of that we know
for a fact that Elsa is hearing a
woman's voice call out to her in frozen
- and from what we gather the voice
belongs to Queen I do know herself but
it's paws
that whoever is calling out to Elsa is
using her mother's voice to fool her
after all the kingdom of arendelle gets
hit with a full-blown threats
the second Elsa that makes contact with
the mysterious symbols magic can be
learned if there's one thing we notice
throughout the new frozen
- trailer it's that lieutenant Matias
was shocked to see Alta using magic he
asked her where did you learn magic
proving that magic can be learned and
mastered although Elsa was born with the
ability to control ice she can learn to
master many other powers clearly Elsa's
abilities are endless and powered by her
desire to believe in something greater
than herself but can be not powerful be
too much for someone to handle it sure
looks like it
you can lose yourself to magic grams
Pappy is full of wisdom and he has
always known that Elsa's powers were too
much for this world but as it turns out
they might be the only thing strong
enough to save it but with great power
comes great responsibility
which is why Anna is Elsa's designated
keeper
she's in scared of Elsa or her magics
and would do anything to save her
according to grand pabbie magic can be
very alluring which is why Elsa needs
Anna to keep her grounded should she get
consumed by power outside forces could
take over arendelle for good magic can
be tamed the elements are out to get the
people of arendelle and those
unfortunate enough to be trapped in the
Enchanted Forest in the trailer we see a
vicious ice horse towering bolder
monsters lively fires and tornadoes so
obviously the elements are trying to get
rid of our heroes but also does
something pretty spectacular
she tamed the wild ice horse by using
her magical powers
- despite how threatening the elements
might seem magic can be tamed by those
who believe it the elements have a mind
of their own at the beginning of the
trailer we see king egg gnar talking to
his girls about the Enchanted Forest see
an enchanted forest there's love and his
voice meaning that this forest holds
some beautiful memories in the magical
reverie we see elements playing with
children in a whimsical way and there's
no threat in sight and looks like
something evil might have taken over
their free will
Elsa's many powers we all know Elsa
as the ice cream but as it turns out
she's much more powerful than that it
looks like Elsa can control all four
elements with the flick of her wrist
there's a reason why Elsa isn't scared
of running into the fire and it's
probably because she can low key control
it by the end of frozen - Elsa might
very well be able to control all four
elements and who knows she might be able
to restore arendelle faith and magic and
teach people how to harness it
the fate of arendelle whoever is calling
out to Elsa desperately wants something
from her the voice sounds like Queen I
do not which makes us wonder if she's
still alive out there could she know a
lot more about the enchanted lands than
she's letting on we mean she looks kind
of suspicious when we left Elsa and
Donna's bedroom
midway through King a ganar story what
do you guys think is also behind the
pink flame as we see in the trailer
sound off in the comments and that's a
wrap
subscribe to the things and give this
video a big thumbs up thanks for
watching we'll see you again soon
[Music]